à l'auto école du manet de montigny le
bretonneux les moteurs des voitures ont
cédé leur place aux moteurs des caméras
une scène d'un téléfilm pour france 2 il
est en effet tourné vague la vie c'est
son nom est tiré d'une histoire vraie et
raconte le parcours d'une femme atteinte
d'un grave cancer du sein
conseillé par son médecin elle intègre
l'équipage d'un bateau composé de femmes
atteintes du même mal leur but sortir de
la maladie est retrouvé goût à la vie
grâce au sport et l'esprit d'équipé
le film coproduit par la société
telfrance base est opérée en yvelines a
principalement été tournée dans le sud
du département
vous voulez situer le film dans une
c'est censé se passer plus petit des
gens tout à papa à paris pas à bordeaux
parlions pas dans une grosse
agglomération la gros gros morceau du
film ça a été sur la base nautique de
saint quentin
puisque c'est là on a tourné toutes les
scènes de bâton les scènes
d'entraînement on a passé huit jours à
la base de saint quentin donc sur 21 ça
quand même été un gros moment avec des
scènes aussi dans le café de la base
nautique est très sympa d'ailleurs
ensuite on a tourné deux jours à
vraiment dans le coeur de saint quentin
dans les galeries marchandes un salon de
coiffure parce que l'amoureuse de didier
qu'il va quitter pour notre mêmes et
coiffeuses la suite du tournage
s'effectuera dans les prochains jours au
studio du père et où l'appartement des
personnages du film a été reconstitué la
fiction sera livré fin 2013 pour une
diffusion courant 2014